foreign
I currently work in a job that's pretty
affected by the political environment
wanted to know how you navigate
political anxiety what kind of job do
you have I work for the federal
government I'm a current member of the
Army National Guard part of entering
into that Community is
you sign away that conversation
[Music]
yo yo what's up this is John the Dr John
deloney's show the greatest mental
health and marriage and parenting
podcast ever recorded
not an exaggeration a little bit of an
exaggeration hope you're doing so good
and I hope that uh we're in this Gap
right between Thanksgiving and Christmas
and I hope no one's playing Little
Drummer Boy wherever you happen to be
got my friends walking through the lobby
there it's good to see you
um man I hope you're I hope you are
heading into the Christmas season
and you're not listen presents under a
Christmas tree it's not a scorecard it
doesn't prove to your kids what kind of
year you had why am I telling you that
because the Black Friday sales are out
records records uh the Cyber Monday data
isn't out it it may be is it records
another wild Cyber Monday
honestly I'm not sure I mean by the time
we by the time this comes out it'll be
out yeah it'll be out but I'm confident
it did well but also it was a record
number of expenditures on credit cards
stop stop
have a hard conversation with your
spouse or your boyfriend or your kids
and they'd have to be hard it can be a
cool over breakfast like hey last year
was a good year this year was a tougher
year and so the Christmas tree is going
to look different this year it's not a
scorecard and hope you're making plans
like what kind of what do we want the
holidays to feel like like things I mean
Christmas and New Year's and let's
reverse engineer that if that means
we're not going to travel we're not
going to travel that means we're not
going to go to in-laws that means we're
not going in-law's house so that means
you want to go early great what does
that look like and remember choose guilt
over resentment when it comes to making
these plans it's a good time to practice
you can do it uh all right let's go oh
by the way don't forget
everybody listen to show you I've been
crushing it thank you so much don't
forget to like
um the show or to do your five star
reviews on the internets liking it were
they liking it on YouTube and subscribe
subscribe do all those things
I'm gonna get this man I'm gonna figure
out how this technology Works you're
doing really good you're doing great I'm
very proud of you every once in a while
uh Kelly comes in just Pats me on the
head and says you're doing good good boy
and then she gives me a small biscuit
and I'm happy for a couple of days all
right let's go to Lynn in Dallas Texas
hey Lynn what's up
hi can you hear me all right I can how
are you
I'm doing good how are you having the
time of my life literally the best day
ever that's probably a stretch yeah but
we're trying right
what's up yes I'm a little nervous here
okay so have you've heard this show
right I know I know I know
we're all it's different though we're
clearly making this up as I go so you're
you're good
okay
um it's kind of a lot so I have like my
little points that I kind of outline so
I'm just gonna go with it very good read
them all let's do it okay
so I basically I grew up in like a
Christian home uh very spiritual
background uh parents or pastors things
like that and so they so you're clearly
traumatized uh yeah you know okay go on
yeah okay and so um
so basically
um
I wasn't like allowed to have a
boyfriend you know things like that
growing up you know kind of stay away
from everything like that so five years
ago
um I'm out on my own working all that
fun stuff and
I was sexually assaulted by a co-worker
really
yeah okay okay so hold on let's just
stop for a second
you are a preacher's kid
and you are masterful
at
having an experience and then quickly
and dutifully brushing it off the table
so it doesn't ruin anybody else's time
and that ends right now
cool
yeah growing up with two parents that
are pastors even if they're wonderful
people doing their best is hard the part
of my life story that I don't tell very
often is that my dad was a homicide
detective for half my life and then he
quit literally over a weekend and became
a pastor
and my life changed
it's hard
and my dad was pretty good at the being
very transparent with me and being open
with me it was still hard right so
um
you grew up in a hard situation and your
parents intentionally
um for what for whatever host of reasons
um didn't allow you to experience
certain types of relationships
and that's hard right
and then a co-worker somebody that
should be safe safe safe
takes everything from you
yeah
how many times have you said that out
loud
this would
I thought
I I wrote it down a lot and so I didn't
think I was
gonna get a little choked up with that
part when I actually said it grief
demands a witness
and I'll sit here with you
um
so that was
five years ago okay
um
but
it makes it a little more rough because
the person that did that was actually
aware that I was saving myself for
marriage and that I hadn't had a
boyfriend and all of that he actually
knew that
um and at the time I was also interning
at a church and so so you take Section
oh hold on so you take sexual assault
and on top of it
you're taking some very clear moral
boundaries that you've drawn for
yourself some boundaries you'd placed on
yourself
in a context and he knowingly
smashed those
and then you throw on top of that how
notoriously awful churches are at
responding to these sorts of things and
that's where you work and so you had to
you were probably the problem if you
said anything so you probably said
nothing
yeah and I don't blame you for that
because you didn't have a context for
that you didn't have parents you could
go to you didn't have friends you could
go to you didn't have co-workers you
could go to and now you can't go to your
church right so you've been your body
has frozen in time
that's why five years later you can say
this out loud for the second time and it
it's like oh is that the light is that
it starts coming out right away right
and you're so good you're so good you
can stamp that stuff out real quick
Fair yeah yes yeah okay I apologize I
keep interrupting you and that's that's
it you're good that's a rude thing to be
for me to be doing right now the last
thing you need is for some idiot to take
away your autonomy yet again so go ahead
and continue I'll do my best to
interrupting you
yeah I I didn't even tell my church for
a year after it actually happened but
since I was there
um I I didn't tell them so I was still
interning at the church and then I kind
of felt like I was playing a role where
people are coming to me and like help
asking for advice for things and then
I've got all this going on on the side
um so when I did tell them about it like
a year later
they
overstepped quite a bit and just like
shoved all sorts of therapy down my
throat and tears resources and so this
is what you need to do and they were
telling everyone so people I didn't even
know were approaching me and telling me
their stories
and so I ultimately left that church
good they don't deserve you they don't
deserve you
can't have that that was a lot so
um I I did go to some of the therapy
just about after that happened
um
and
I felt like I was making progress now
I'm starting to question that
I'm telling the story
um but I I feel like I've made some good
progress over the last four years
um as a result of that
which is kind of good information to
know the way that I kind of coped with
that situation was by starting to drink
I started drinking pretty heavily I did
start sleeping around a little bit
um and so I did that for about a year
okay so can I pause you can I can I have
your permission to cut you off for a
second yes yes okay
um super super common response you're
not crazy
a very common response to having
somebody steal your sexuality from you
is an attempt to reclaim ownership of it
yeah does that make sense by entering
into a whole bunch of other sexual
relationships so that I I am in control
and I will exert it and it's often
followed by feeling really bad about
yourself and shameful and so the way
we're gonna overcome feeling bad about
ourselves is we're going to reclaim it
even more
and sometimes those experiences escalate
um or they accelerate and they uh get
riskier right but I'm I'm in control
right so that's super common and alcohol
literally the problem with alcohol is it
works until it kills you yeah yeah it
does shut the it shuts everything off
it does and so I want you to hear me say
you're not crazy you're not a terrible
human being okay
yeah
yeah okay all right back in
play yeah
so um I I stopped that stopped stopped
sleeping around
um cut back a lot of the drinking got a
new therapist new psychiatrist so I've
really been working on myself really
trying to kind of heal and recover from
that very cool so
um
now
I'm getting to the point
where I want to start dating want to
start finding someone
and I've kind of set my own new kind of
boundaries and standards and what I
would like to happen all right hold on I
got to cut you off again
Lynn
you're not gonna kind of maybe set me no
you're freaking Lynn from Dallas
here's my boundaries this is the way I'm
Gonna Roll because I'm Lynn from Dallas
and I don't give a crap what you think
or what you say none zero
until
we have enough of a relationship that I
give you access to my heart which by the
way is mine to give out not my parents
not my crappy church that failed me not
the people who have been asking for my
advice and wisdom for all these years I
decide
and then when you give access to
somebody then you care
right then they have permission my wife
has permission to hurt me which means
she also has permission to love me
deeply
okay and those things work in tandem but
right now no no I'm kind of thinking
about some boundaries no Lynn you're all
in you're a gangster dude nobody's
messing with Lynn right right yes yes
good okay play
Okay so
the boundaries that I have set
are that when I find the right person I
don't want to have sex until we're
married right I think that that's very
honoring to God and I want our
relationship to start out in that way
can I ask you this
does it honor you
it does okay
you have to be a part of the honoring
equation
you can't leave yourself out
okay you've left yourself out your whole
life
or let me put it this way everyone left
you out
and nobody bothered to tell you that you
were worth honoring too
and so
if your relationship and your to God and
your faith and your psychology work and
all of this has led you to a place where
this is what I want for me
then you owe nobody any explanation for
that none
zero
whatever it may be
okay
yeah you're worth being honored
and you get to decide what that honoring
looks like
cool
yeah I hate that nobody's ever told you
that
yeah you should have got that that
your parents aren't here to defend
themselves so I'm gonna not talk about
them no all right go ahead
yeah
um so the the issue that I've been
running into
uh when it comes to starting to to date
and having clear
expectations of who I'm interested in
someone like-minded shares the same
belief things like that
um the issue that I'm having is either
I'll find someone that is also saving
themselves and once I tell them about my
past history they'll usually say sorry
I'm looking for someone that's you know
weighted and all of that which is fair
or I run into the people that say they
have the same values and it's so cool
but then they'll also say well I think
we should move in together and we should
definitely have sex anyway and we're
going to get married so it's fine and
not what I want and so the question
which I think you sort of answered a
little bit already was if I should
adjust my boundaries to kind of be more
aligned with my options yes you should
absolutely compromise your values I
think you're set your boundaries too
high
You're Expecting too much of people and
you should water down what you feel and
what you think is right
so that uh somebody will like you
that sounds insane right it does yeah
don't do that
don't do that yeah
it's real real frustrating right now
because you've put in a ton of work to
heal
and you're lonely is all bloody hell
right
yeah and this is the part that gets left
out of the conversation sex is
connecting
it does make you feel less alone for a
season it has a back end to it right
that makes it
it has a downstream effect that makes
you lonelier over time right if you're
just if you're being used for sex you're
using other people for sex right and
that's not religious woo-woo that's out
of the scientific literature
but
it is connecting
and when you cut that off cold turkey
and you quit drinking suddenly you're
faced with this Stark real pain from a
sexual assault you're having to deal
with and stare down and walk through
parents who didn't show up for you
because they were too busy doing things
not of this Earth
right yeah and it's lonely
and so
you could get in line with millions and
millions and millions of other people
who have just settled
and just said and now and I'm not saying
like no bro she's got to be a perfect 10
and if she doesn't have abs and well
those idiots not talking about that I'm
talking about settling on the things
that as we talked about earlier honor
you and you get to choose those things
yeah right
yeah what I would recommend is backing
out of the romance part of all of this
do you have a group of friends you just
go hang with
I don't you don't
because you're probably not religious
enough for the Jesus Freaks and you're
probably too Faith oriented for people
that you think are just regular people
is that fair
you nailed it and
some of my best friends on the planet
are atheist
some of them and I'm a Christian guy for
those some of my best friends in the
world have different political ideas
than me have lives that look very
different than mine
and that changed when I quit being an
arrogant idiot assuming that other
people were going to be certain ways
okay and so what you need is a healthy
dose of just good old-fashioned
friendship
which means you're gonna have to just go
be weird
and hospitable and say I'm having a
holiday get together everybody come over
and bring whatever you got left in your
house
and I'm gonna Lynn I'm gonna give you
all the questions for humans let me give
you every one of them except for the
parents and kids ones and you're just
like we're just gonna ask doc we're
gonna hang out and play this stupid
questions thing that this podcaster gave
me and we're just gonna go down rabbit
holes and if you invite seven or eight
people three or four might come
yeah right and the other three or four
you were raised in a house where it's
your job to make sure everybody else was
okay you got to quit doing that because
it's an exhausting task that's not your
job
those three or four people are not going
to come you know why because of things
they're going through not because of you
or it might be because of you because
you're weird who cares yeah because of
them they don't want to go cool I'm not
going to hang on to that I'm gonna
invite people to my house
and if only two show up cool we'll eat
whatever half casserole we got left and
whatever weird box of cereal you had
left and oh you got like a quarter
bottle of wine let's just mix them all
together and create and we'll have that
and we're just gonna play games
or if you're trying not to drink cool
we're gonna have a Diet Coke Fest
whatever is we're doing and we're gonna
get to know each other and out of that
group one or two people will emerge as
we connected I like that dude I like her
she's pretty cool
what you really need practice at is
relationship
because you're running into these things
looking for Romance
without the skill set of how to be a
friend
how to be in somebody else's space does
that make sense yes and so let's
practice being in other people's space
and what's going to emerge out of that
is uh some ooh romance gross
and somebody's gonna show up with some
guy who's gonna bring it him over and
you're gonna be like hmm and he's going
to be like hmm and then it's just going
to get gross and weird
right
yeah
and then you'll have had time to
practice relationship you know I've had
time to practice telling the truth and
practice being vulnerable and practice
being intimate and open without sex
those are all skills they're not moral
issues or character flaws they're just
skills man and most of us don't have
those skills we had to learn them
is that cool
yeah you trust me
I do okay here's what we're looking for
fun
laughter
like from your guts
being able to say yeah I was sexually
assaulted sucked
took five years of my life
it took a big part of my identity it
just stole it I've had a lot of healing
what about you
can you imagine being able to do that
not in a flippant way not in a lack of
compassion way but in a way that my body
doesn't react anymore on me
because I've been through the trauma
healing part of this thing and now I can
talk about it as a cautionary tale now I
can talk about it as a
um I am I am
really convicted about women having the
opportunity and the right to speak on
behalf of their own bodies you see what
I'm saying
yeah there's a powered strength that
comes from the other side of grieving
and healing
okay and you're worth all of that yeah
Fair yeah yeah yeah that's that's fair
do not compromise
the things that honor you
and since you're a person that shares my
same Faith trajectory don't compromise
on things that uh
you believe dishonor God
okay
make choices in the present that future
Lynn is going to be really grateful that
you made even when they're hard
foreign
that's fair okay so before uh
um
you got 72 hours three days
is that three days yes I don't know how
math worked
you got three days to set up an event at
your apartment or your house wherever
you live
cool
okay and I'll get all these things out
in the mail to you and I'm uh I want you
to use them I want you to have fun and
if you don't use the cards that's cool
man watch Die Hard the greatest
Christmas movie of all time uh like
watch old movies whatever it is
but let's get weird and let's be
hospitable let's go first let's invite
people over and we're going to start
making friends
and if they want to opt out cool and if
they just want to talk about politics
and covet well then that's probably not
this prize in the house for you
or we're gonna have hard conversations
whatever it is whatever it is
you're worth being in relationship with
you're worth being friends with
and yes you're worth romantic love and
it will come it will it will happen it
will happen it will happen
so I'm blessed to have gotten to speak
with you and talk to you thank you for
being brave and being open please
apologize the last thing you needed was
some idiot interrupting you 45 times and
I apologize
foreign
you're so worth being loved
and it's on the way we'll be right back
hey guys deloney here and I've got a
word from our sponsor whoop if you've
listened to the show for any length of
time you know I'm a major nerd about
Fitness sleep mental health and building
healthier life habits and let's just say
this whoop makes my nerd heart so happy
one reason I love whoop is that it's not
like all the other fitness trackers that
mix in a watch in laser lights and
smiley faces and a million notifications
and reminders that you you need to get
your steps in no whoop is a fitness
wearable that actually looks cool and
it's comfortable and it gives you data
that really matters it breaks down your
recovery your sleep and your daily
strain into a format that's easy to
interpret and some days I wake up in the
green and this tells me that I'm ready
to go attack the day and other days I
wake up in the red and I know that I
gotta take it easy and I can look back
in time and see how I got there if
you're working to be intentional and
build healthier habits whoop can help
you get there start keeping an eye on
your health and wellness at a deeper
level go to whoop dot com that's
w-h-o-oop.com and use promo code deloni
to get 10 off your order today
all right we're back hey before we move
on Ben it's your birthday dude
it is yes 22
31 30 but thank you 31
dude I didn't know you'd cross the big
3-0 I was just thinking everybody like
has challenges with their first job or
their first big like whatever
in 20 years you're so good at this
you're going to be like ah you're gonna
just be sitting around a bunch of dudes
and be like remember this one show I had
to start on oh you think your first job
was bad I had to be on this one guy show
man so I'm glad that we got you at the
beginning here this is the highlight of
my career I don't know what you're
talking about yeah but you're 31. she's
just fair yeah it's the Highlight all
right
it's the only light so it's pretty low
light maybe it's the it will be the low
light in very short order man well happy
birthday man you got any fun plans going
out to dinner Taqueria del Sol queso
marks queso
dude we are changing America one bull
okay so at a time Amen brother that's
fantastic well congratulations on making
it to the big three one that's awesome
all right uh let's go to Aaron in Eugene
Oregon what's up Aaron how's it going
good brother what's up
it's good to talk to you YouTube yeah
I'll go with my question I uh constantly
right now kind of feel like I'm in
crisis mode
um I'm getting pretty burnt out and uh
I feel like I'm having trouble leading
my family uh let it come on
leading myself like spiritually mentally
why are you in crisis mode man
well
um so my wife and I have been married
for three years we have two daughters
ages two and one
um we own a business so we started about
two years ago so we're pretty busy right
now I generally work about 14 hours a
day six days a week
um in July we found out that my wife was
pregnant
and months later we found out that she
was pregnant with two babies we were
having twins wow
um and then uh fast forward to October
my wife went in for like a regular
ultrasound
I wasn't able to be there I had to work
and they told her that the twins were
in high high risk very very dangerous
situation that we needed to operate
um
and so we we've been in for surgery that
that day
um
and they the twins survived about three
four days after the surgery
we lost him
um
so yeah kind of in the aftermath of that
yeah
um and just
yeah no I just don't have time to deal
with that right now because we're we're
so busy our businesses are peak season
yeah
so it's just been
24 7 non-stop kind of thing yeah man
dude I'm sorry
I'm so sorry man
um
I can't I can't think of a
more radical trauma than losing two
twins with a two and a one-year-old on
top of that on top of a very young
marriage on top of a young business
trying to make it y'all got a lot man
so you say you're overwhelmed you should
be okay you're not crazy
and you're burning out and you are
melting down you should be
okay
and I'll walk with you on what some
things you can do but
man
how's your wife doing
um
she's doing she's doing well
um like physically she's recovering
very well
um but you know it's
I'm not around to help as much as I
would like with the kids so what's your
business man it's hard on her
uh we have a mobile tire shop so we go
out to people's homes and and deliver
and install their tires okay excellent
um do you have people that work with you
or for you
uh we have one employee currently
okay
um are you just scratching are you just
scratching a clawing to make a living
are y'all doing pretty well
um like I would hire you to come to my
house right now and change my tires like
that sounds like an incredible business
yeah we're we're doing
I wouldn't say we're just scratching and
crying but it it's
owning your own business you know
everything kind of gets reinvested for
the first few years so it's not like
we're You Know Rich by any means yeah
yeah I mean yeah personally our finances
are really tight because we reinvest
everything into the business okay that
makes sense
I can't think of a better investment
right now
than to get some help and get you some
space
if you don't deal with the chaos in your
home and in your life and in your soul
right now it will deal with you
and it will take no mercy on you
and so when you're talking about an
investment in the business
sometimes the like
uh
if you are Usain Bolt and you are
training for yet another Olympics
a huge part of your training is rest
you're not just running Sprints every
single minute of every single day you
run really hard for a short burst and
then you rest
and right now your world just exploded
it already was chaotic with a two and a
one-year-old and a three-year-old
marriage
y'all barely said hello as a as a
married couple before you started
cranking out kids and then you had a big
time traumatic loss because you that's
long enough you made plans right
yeah you start thinking about life with
twins and two knucklehead little boys
running around
what were their names
Lawrence and Andrew yeah
they had names man they had to put the
place in your house
they had a place in your heart
you can't outrun that
you're gonna have to sit and own that
loss
and own that grief
and there's not a road map for that per
se but that's something that you and
your wife are gonna have to do
I just know too many couples that don't
grieve or they grieve differently
everybody agrees differently but they
grieve so differently that it splits
their marriage up it splits their
relationship up the younger kids feel
like they're crazy
because Mom's crying and they're
wondering what they did my mom's upset
dad's never like see what I'm saying
and I'm all about man I just I'm coming
off a season about to enter into another
season
um
of intense 14 16 hour days day after day
after day after day I get it there's
Seasons when you do that but you can't
run that way forever particularly on the
back of a trauma
is that fair
yeah your business may not be need to
grow grow for the next six months it may
need to just stay neutral just keep just
keep going keep doing great work and
hire two guys to come help so that you
can go home
and sit with your wife
there will be Seasons when you go back
to the 14-hour days and go back to the
grind you go back and doing those things
it's going to be important and it's
going to be good stuff it's gonna be
right
um
right now you're the UFC fighter who got
knocked out
and whose body is so programmed to keep
going that he hops back up and just
starts swinging again ends up swinging
at the raft or tries to tackle the ref
you gotta and then it takes his coaches
and the doctor to sit him down and so
you got to stop
that's where you are man
now when I say that it's easier for me
to say that here in Nashville I'm not
I'm not in the middle of a busy season
there in Eugene or whatever
could you create a world where you work
nine hours a day and then go home
is that possible
um
I don't know it seems like it's probably
worth trying though
I think you're worth that I think your
sweet wife is worth that I think those
little baby girls are worth that
and I think honoring the memory of your
two boys
Lawrence sander I think it's worth it
I think it's worth it
but I can guarantee you as the pace
you're moving
with the weight of the bricks you're
carrying is not sustainable
and I love you too much to tell you it's
all good man just just keep crushing
yeah is that fair
yeah I think so yeah and how you choose
to heal and how y'all choose to
um
grief is like a fingerprint dude
um ever it's different for everybody
sitting down with your wife and asking
how you're going to grieve this what
does she need
um what does that look like and let's
say this maybe you can't take time off
of work
so hire a high school kid or a college
student to come home for four hours a
night and help your wife out
and you're going to get behind
financially and or not get behind but
you're gonna you're gonna stay afloat or
you're gonna take some of your business
expenses and you're going to have to
roll them back in and Char you have to
pay yourself more for the hours you're
putting in and you take that money and
you roll it back and you help out with
so get your wife some help so she can
get some breathing room
so you can have some space to feel
my wife and I lost three pregnancies and
I tattooed the names of those babies on
my body and it has provided great
conversations for me and my kids as
they've asked questions daddy who's that
and why you have that name right below
our names and what is it so that's
that's how that's the conversation we
had in our house and my wife and I have
had to grieve it differently in
different Cycles throughout our marriage
don't let that split y'all up go into it
direct and be be clear about it man
when you talk about leading your family
unable to lead yourself
sometimes the greatest thing a leader
can do is to take a knee and say
I need to I need to tap somebody else I
need to tap out
and you tap somebody else in
and you stop for a second
I need to call some men who I trust and
I need them to hold my arms up in the
desert because I can't hold them up on
my own right now
I need to call a friend I need to get
some help I need to get some support I
need to hire a couple more people even
though it's gonna really make a tough
financially for us
whatever we got to do
to put your marriage first to put those
two little babies second and then put
the rest of your life after that
[Music]
I'm heartbroken with you I'm sorry
[Music]
I want you and your wife to write those
two little boys a letter about how much
you miss them
but all the cool things that you had
planned for them
and I want y'all to read your letters to
each other
and that'll be step one on a new healing
path for you and her and those two
little baby girls
are we thinking about you my brother
we'll be right back
deloney here and I've got a word from
this episode sponsor betterhelp let's
all be honest life would be way easier
if it came with a user manual marriage
parenting work making friends especially
as adults but this is the truth my
friends there's no step-by-step guide
you have to take ownership of your life
and when it feels like too much or you
feel stuck or overwhelmed it's too easy
to get lost in the anxiety black hole
I've been there but you can learn to
navigate this beautiful chaos we call
life in a healthy way therapy gives you
the tools to do just that and that's why
I love better help better help is online
therapy that offers video phone even
live chat sessions with your therapist
there's no waiting rooms no traffic no
endlessly searching for the right
therapist that happens to not take your
insurance listen better help us
connected more than three million people
with licensed therapists and they can
match you with a therapist at under 48
hours so don't settle for feeling stuck
visit betterhelp.com com deloney today
to learn more and get 10 off your first
month that's betterhelp.com deloney
all right we're gonna go out to
Cheyenne Wyoming and talk to Devon
what's up Devin
hey how you doing Dr John I'm good man
what's happening in your world
uh well we got five inches of snow I'm
leaving the gym right now great job
going to the gym in the snow that was a
dope flex and anybody listening to this
you're gonna sound Awesome by the way
like I'll just snow once I want to get
ripped what workout did you do today
uh we were doing back today
we're doing that ah are you a bro or
like you like got a jacked up truck and
you're just crushing it
I really wish I had a jacked up truck I
have a small little Nissan Frontier that
I can't even fit my two babies
good for you man you're my hero
um all right so what's uh I don't know
understand this five inches of snow
business that would be an apocalypse
here in Nashville uh but what's up man
how can I help
so I submitted the question
um I currently work in a job that's
pretty affected by the political
environment
and wanted to know especially like with
all the uncertainty going on around you
know elections and the current political
environment how you navigate like
political anxiety
oh man that's a great question
um what kind of job do you have that's
contingent on politics I currently I
actually kind of have two I work for the
federal government both of them I'm a
current member of the Army National
Guard okay and I also work for the uh
Veterans Affairs Medical Center here
okay
um so what are what are your bigger
concerns are you worried about policies
are you worried about mandates what do
you what are you worried about
no uh mostly policies
um especially fiscal policy that could
affect you know my job oh okay so if
some if somebody came in and cut a bunch
of like uh defense spending or if
somebody came in and like uh if you work
in the medical establishment when they
mandated
um like in the original Desert Storm
those guys were going over and they got
like 500 shots and then the guys who
went over for operation
um Iraqi Freedom Got 5 000 shots and
then like the the coveted vaccine
mandates like so I'm not a veteran I
spent a lot of my career with him but
I'm not one my understanding is part of
entering into that Community is
you sign away that conversation
does that make sense
yeah I mean that's true and so I guess
backing out of it like I don't give
politics a second of my life none zero
and so if you're in a job that is
contingent on I guess any job at any
time could be subject to they're being
challenges in the marketplace challenges
in your boss decides hey we don't want
to I think Amazon just decided hey we're
not going to do Alexa anymore instead of
laying off thousands of people like that
just happens
and that's why having
a building a non-anxious life having an
emergency fund not onlybody any money
choosing to drive a Nissan Frontier
instead of being a goofball and taking a
hundred thousand dollar truck loan out
right
um it sounds like you're doing the
things that allow you to if they came in
and cut a bunch of defense spending and
you suddenly found yourself laid off
from the federal government and from the
Veterans Administration which I highly
doubt
um then you're going to be super
qualified to go figure out something
else
is that fair
oh yeah that's true what's bigger is
there something underneath this what is
it
um as a lot of exempts from it you know
we
and we have a hard
through baby step for steps we've
backtracked into baby set too we've
backtracked into baby step one got our
way back to baby step three okay and now
we're back in baby step two for people
listening um I work at Ramsey Solutions
and we have a program for teaching
people how to get out of debt and help
millions and millions of people get out
of debt and take control get just get
freedom in their life
um and so uh when Devon's here's talking
about baby steps one and two and three
that's just a series of steps that
people follow to get themselves out of
debt forever
um
the debit card is not going to magically
save you why do you keep why do you keep
borrowing money let me ask you that way
we the only reason we actually went back
into debt now was because of the right
now like five inches of snow my wife is
a stay-at-home mom and she didn't have a
car that could get through it to get our
son to school
and so that was the only reason I was
like you know what you need a car and we
went back in the debt and stresses me
out it should it should yeah luckily we
got it in June it'll be paid off like
right at the beginning of the year but
okay so be done with it be done with it
yeah and then put yourself in your
family in a position that that doesn't
ever happen again
yeah that's my goal we can't cancel all
our credit cards close the accounts good
good for you hold it next time we get a
car it's going to be because we saved up
our money good for you we traded this in
and we're going to do it in cash yeah
it's good for you man good for you so
here's what I've found in my life when I
start getting anxious about things
one of the things our bodies do is it
starts looking for threats there are
things that identifies threats
one of the ways we do we that manifest
in our current world because we don't
have bears chasing us anymore is it
turns into we turn uh the world into us
as in themselves we try to find somebody
to blame for our internal state
and what I would suggest is build a life
the best you can
so that not if but when your division
gets laid off when some knucklehead
politician makes some sweeping change
just so they can get some more votes
when your boss
gets caught you know with uh cocaine and
gets fired and then everybody go when
all that happens it's annoying it's not
catastrophic does that make sense
yeah
um and so that I mean
I just don't give politicians the access
into my life like that
yes I pay a ton of taxes
okay
like I no amount of worrying is gonna
make my tax bill lower
no amount of me like banging on things
and hitting things and getting mad is
gonna solve that right
true so I I just tend to go to things I
can control and then move on
um I don't know they can't make your
wife like you more they can't pay off
your house they clearly can't forgive
your student loans even though they're
trying to like they just can't I mean
I'm just not gonna give that to them
so let me ask you this why have you
given it to him
oh man dude break the cycle
break the cycle put Andy Griffith on the
TV
funny enough that's actually what we
play on our TV at the VA yeah you play
Andy Griffith that'll cheer everybody up
that's a good upstanding guy
um
break that cycle man
let your kids believe that their
neighborhood and their community and
their local church and their integrity
and hard work and discipline
daily practices that that has much more
to do has much more influence on their
future than some suit in some Capitol
Building somewhere
yeah that sounds like a good plan is
that fair
I I just
you sound like a young dad who's really
busting his butt and kicking butt and
working hard and
you found yourself with your pants down
again it snowed five inches not
literally your pants down but it snowed
five inches and all of a sudden you like
went and bought a car and I kind of I
feel sick doing this just on a borrowing
money on depreciating asset at 14
interest or whatever they're charging
now
man
choose Freedom every time freedom from
the television telling you what to do
and how to live your life choose freedom
from I'm not going to owe anybody any
money because I don't want them speaking
into my life
I want to decide what I do tomorrow not
Toyota Motor Company I want to decide
what I do tomorrow not some toxic boss
that abuses me
I want to decide what me and my family
where we're going to live and what we're
going to do not some politicians man I'm
just not going to give that person those
people access into my soul do I vote
yeah do I participate yes absolutely I
do and I go to Carnival and I throw my
one ping pong ball into the little bowl
hoping I get a goldfish and sometimes my
man or woman wins and sometimes they
don't then I'm done worrying about it
because no amount of Rage or anger
doesn't make gas prices any cheaper it
doesn't make
um us go to war or not go to war it just
doesn't
so I'm gonna get to know my neighbors
I'm going to get to know my community
I'm gonna get invested in local politics
if that's that's for me not some
national politician but hey we need a
road over here hey we need a group of
people to help with the bridge over here
we need a new restaurant in our
community like whatever that looks like
for you but I'm not I'm just not giving
them that time and hopefully
um go to ramseysolutions.com if you
found yourself owning a whole whole
bunch of money
um if you find yourself in debt
because I tell you there's very few
things that will set you and your
marriage and your parenting
Freer than not own anybody anything and
there's a step-by-step program Financial
Peace University to get you out of debt
it's pretty it's extraordinary they
changed my family's trajectory man
changed our whole family tree
um check that out but beyond all
don't get into Political stress they
just don't get that they don't get they
don't get rent free space in my head
anymore the space up here is expensive
now and if I know one thing uh they like
to spend other people's money not theirs
so they're not going to be renting my
headspace anytime soon we'll be right
back
it seems so but most of us way
undervalue real genuine relationships
our friendships our marriages we don't
know what we're doing and instead of
diving into the mess we accept
shallowness and distraction and we
wallpaper over our loneliness so let me
say this boldly you cannot be well alone
you've got to get connected to real life
people and have deep powerful
relationships I'm talking about
relationships where you can be honest
where you can open up where you can
share hard things and you each know that
you'll still show up for each other and
in my new book own your past change your
future we'll walk through a not so
complicated approach to relationships
mental health and wellness and getting
connected is a key part of that that's
why you'll learn shallowness and
loneliness are so dangerous and more
importantly you'll learn how to create
meaningful relationships in your life
moving forward there is no good app to
help adults find friendships but this
book can help go to John deloney.com to
take the next step towards Wellness
that's own your past change your future
dot com
all right as we wrap up today's show in
honor of uh five inches of snow in
Cheyenne Wyoming
um Kelly went bald with this one y'all
y'all wouldn't know this he doesn't wear
shorts a lot but she has like starting
at her hip all the way down to her ankle
a huge Old English tattoo of her of her
favorite rapper ever Vanilla Ice
strange I wouldn't have got that tattoo
but it does look rad it's weird when she
wears shorts around the office but
Vanilla Ice her favorite favorite song
um
Ice Ice Baby
and occasionally you'll hear her just
singing the lyrics As She uh goes about
the things she's doing just be walking
down the hallway yo VIP let's kick it
she just Whispers it to herself all
right stop collaborate and listen and
she's like yeah go Kelly go Kelly go ice
is back with a brand new intervention
something grabs a hold of me tightly and
then Kelly flows like a harpoon daily
and nightly will it ever stop yo I don't
know but Kelly turns out the lights and
She Glows to the extreme she walks a mic
like a candle nope
sure excellent Mike like whatever dude
this is America we'll see you soon I
love y'all
[Music]